hey I want to play a video for you that
is really really good because it brings
out a conversation that is a necessary
conversation to have you know how
Republicans love to say we have our uh
violent blue States and violent blue
cities and it's so dangerous to be in
what they call Democrat cities of course
it's not true
and yesterday or this might be actually
from the day before is this yesterday I
guess yeah for this this is from
yesterday there was a debate yesterday
wherein sitting Oklahoma governor
Kevin's tit
um is being challenged by Democratic
Challenger Joy Hoffmeister and Stitt
tries the typical stuff uh Democrats are
bad for crime and Democratic states are
dangerous and he's they love to
scapegoat New York and New York City and
to her credit Joy Hofmeister points out
hey you know what Kevin uh violent crime
is higher in Oklahoma than it is in New
York and she's completely correct I'm
going to give you the data this is not a
matter of opinion he simply says no that
can't possibly be true and there's
something that the audience does that's
very revealing about how these
Republicans think and behave take a
listen to this so let's talk about the
facts the fact is
the rates of violent crime are higher in
Oklahoma under your watch than in New
York and California that's a fact
well we'll have that fact checked by the
frontier superintendent it's also a fact
that medicines do you believe we have
higher crime than New York or California
that's why she just said
Safety and Security is my so Kevin's tit
says that doesn't sound right you you
people don't believe that right and the
cloud goes no no this is the way they
operate it just doesn't sound like the
very stuff we've been repeating so it
can't possibly be true right but it is
very much true these red state folks
have no idea that they are being lied to
and that blue cities and blue states are
being scapegoated for no reason that has
any connection to reality they don't
have any idea how violent their states
are if it doesn't sound right it must
not be wrong and of course the reason it
doesn't sound right is because they're
constantly lied to about it but it is
true if you look at the rate okay the
rate is crimes per population of course
a state with a dramatically higher
population is likely to have more a
higher number of violent primes because
there's Millions more people in a lot of
these high population States but what we
care about is the rate we care about the
rate it's sort of like if I say more
people died of covid in Florida than in
Wyoming
that doesn't really tell us much because
Florida's population is so much larger
similarly if I say there are more crimes
in New York City than in Savannah it
doesn't really tell us much because New
York City has so many more people if you
look at the rates Oklahoma was most
recently ranked 15th highest in the
country for rate of violent crime and
New York state was 26th it is without
question
that Oklahoma has a higher rate of
violent crime than New York State and in
fact this isn't really rare if you look
this is public data I don't I don't
claim to have any kind of Monopoly on
the data if you look up top states by
violent crime
uh rate
of the top 10 states you've got seven
very red States
one purple State uh Nevada
uh and then you've got Washington DC and
then there's like one more purple stage
I guess it's two purples it's seven red
States two purple States in Washington
DC which is in a state but it's a
territory it's red States it's red
states with the highest violent crime
rates now you could say well David sir
you're being deceptive forget about
Oklahoma and New York State what about
Oklahoma City and New York City fine
dude make the same comparison in 2022 so
far the Oklahoma violent crime rate is
40. and New York City is 28. that's this
is a one to 100 where a higher number
means more violent crime New York City's
violent crime rate is significantly
lower than the violent crime rate in
Oklahoma City and by the way the
property crime rate is also dramatically
lower in New York City 25 versus 60 in
Oklahoma City they don't care about the
facts
Democrats run New York City it must be
more violent well okay not true now I I
can't get off of this topic without
mentioning one other important thing
this entire conversation is also skewed
because in general
cities have more violence because of
more population density cities tend to
be more democratic and often in blue
States but red States also have cities
and they're often significantly more
violent and the safest big cities are
all in very very blue States but there's
this base rate bias where Democrats tend
to prefer to live in cities versus
conservatives and that's a systemic
reality even still the numbers are not
what these Republicans claim them to be
so Kevin's tit laughing it off
absolutely true uh what Joy Hoffmeister
said there the David packman shows
longest running sponsor is blinkist the
app that takes thousands of non-fiction
books boils each of them down into an
explainer you can read or listen to in
15 minutes blinkist also condenses
episodes of popular podcasts into
15-minute explainers I've been using
blinkist for years to supplement the
books I read I love reading I I read all
the time but there's even more books I
don't have time to read and you can
often find those non-fiction books on
blinkist and consume the entire thing in
15 minutes my favorite new feature on
the app is blinkist connect which lets
you share your blinkist premium account
with someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users I have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist Sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to Robert Greene's the 48 Laws of Power
the new version Robert Greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com davidpakman
the link is down below